hey John now when you do the
introduction mm-hmm can you introduce me
as Joker like I did on TV yeah sure
hey guys I'm Greg and he's Joker yeah
thanks John we are going to do a spoiler
talk for Joker 2019 move or to pray if
you haven't seen our non spoiler
discussion highly recommend you go check
that out you know cuz there's no point
in just repeating sure some stuff will
be repeated but there's no point in
repeating everything that was said there
long story short it has been a full day
since we have watched Joker I woke up
this morning just thinking so much about
it went to work out and then when I was
exercising I was still thinking about
this movie and I'm like yeah I
definitely love this movie very moody to
like thinking about more things just how
powerful it is and you hear the
conversations that I'm here like things
I completely disagree with I'm like but
that's part of why this movie how's it
going on you since yesterday John yeah I
mean it's definitely still on my mind
there are things that have become just
better in my mind things I like more and
I did and then there are also some
things that I'm still kind of chewing on
but yeah I'm sort of with you in the
sense that my favorite part of this is
that no interaction I've had with this
movie has been standard like
everything's been kind of strange and
unusual and that's the most exciting
thing to me stream pretty special
because not many movies do that now hmm
well we got plenty of topics we need to
cover it it was gonna be a free-form
talk it's probably best workout bullet
points I just figured why not let's
gamble here let's see if we can keep a
coherent video going but you know we
have some things that we know we
definitely got to cover we really what
are the must covers on here what are you
gonna get mad at us about for not
covering later just put it in the
comments a couple of notes I think my
mom's gone crazy and some clever with my
own personal reference the family
history of mental illness psychological
physical abuse you know fun stuff Arthur
Fleck not the son of Thomas Wayne by the
way spoiler how do you like videos
called spoiler talks then you got to
give a sport the reward
a simple blind legally having ignored
every your fault who's your fault I got
it sport I didn't read the title of the
video my autoplay Bruce Wayne scenes
Murray Franklin show the ending riot
full transformation by the end of it all
all the main kills from subway station -
mommy apartment the little man he
doesn't kill a little man but we'll go
over that scene cops
Murray of course as Ozzy beats as the
girlfriend and you know like the final
scene and then there's a bunch of other
things to go over as well those are just
some things we want to make sure we do
eventually get to but yeah this movie is
really impacting me dude
I find it very affecting I'm like
there's a certain standard here and I
wonder how future movies will be
affected by feel like this movie is just
gonna be a box-office hit and I'm
wondering how Somers future of origin
movies and what they do with revamping
characters will be affected by because
it'd be cool to see more movies have a
take like this but it seems I don't want
them to just do but make the Juvia how I
remove it was like how do we Batman
Begins this I don't want every movie to
be how do we Joker origin this from here
on out but sticking to the movie itself
I think from the very beginning I was
like I think this is my kind of movie
for sure I thought it's such a good job
at setting up themes you start off where
he's and he's like dealing with the
makeup and the chair from the scene the
trailer that everyone's making fun to
learn forcing the smile snapping it back
the tears are coming out the tone and
the themes I thought were so well
established from the very beginning of
its pacing how this movie's really gonna
take its time with a lot of scenes but
also setting up the theme of sad clown
even with the whole and I think we
actually talked about this perhaps in
our trailer breakdown when the sign is
stolen and then the kids like you know
smash it on him and the sign says
everything must go yes that isn't you
know is the the job he's working at the
time but I think fanatically really pay
attention that is like that theme of his
characters really chosen sighs yeah
because he's sort of been anything he's
stripping away everything of Arthur
Fleck everything that he held dear to or
things that he was afraid to confront
any dynamic relationship work it's like
any attempt to manage what's going on
and yeah you know everything must go and
he really does
let go of everything you know whether
that by letting go we're killing it
directly yes so having it crushed
horribly you know yeah circumstance yeah
so I think in structurally speaking I I
think that's really cool and definitely
a very intentional sign that just
happens to work really well within an
actual job that someone would have yeah
that's it we're done talking spoilers
everything great go we'll listen to
beyond the trailer or Jeremy Jones I got
great spoiler sure they do have to
listen to them but I'm sure they're good
one of the biggest things that comes
directly to my mind is the debate about
the ending I mean the very ending
because that's sort of the one element
that I think we both didn't take the way
a lot of other people are taking it mhm
and so you know the films that's how
we're gonna do this review we're gonna
do the third the last scene let's talk
about the ending well not be like final
final scene I think you're referring to
the death of Thomas and Martha Wayne
initially I was going in there and then
I switched to the final scene okay why
don't we go to Thomas and Martha Wayne
because I feel like that is one element
of this movie that at least in my
opinion the way they handled it kind of
diverted from everything else it was the
one thing that truly felt out of place
to me the way they did it because I felt
like such a left turn into let's take a
sidebar to just recreate the origin that
we all know from Batman yeah took it too
far for me a little bit in the sense
that it's already cute and clever that
they're like all work switching it up
and Joker's responsible I got the point
you know it's like I could have used a
subtle or take on that I think yeah I
mean even our non-spoiler review we
talked about some comic book II things
that we were like we didn't really find
necessary it's so spine it yeah like
this is really not a thing I don't want
to spend too much time on it did pull me
out made me think comic book movie
because they're doing like such a
different take on Thomas Wayne
especially then it just goes into like
the alleyway the jewel necklace yeah I
like the fact that it wasn't Arthur who
killed him I wonder if that was just an
intentional choice because the fact that
Jack Nicholson's Joker did kill
Bruce Wayne's parents and the flashback
of 89 Batman anyway either way I'm glad
it wasn't it wasn't him in a lot of ways
it still is Joker is responsible for the
death of the parents I think it would
have been a little bit more effective if
it was alluded to like they watched them
that clown whatever watches him walking
out and follows him into the alley yeah
the cameras just like pulling away from
the alleyway yeah just watch them
disappear into the alley right yeah that
guy he did goes into the alleyway and
then you know we cut off or something
like yeah yeah like you know like you
know you know it does Ozzy beats death I
don't know if it's a death but that's
what I mean it's like it's an open to
interpretation moment whereas that
moment if he if he changed the way the
the Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne death
went down in this movie it wouldn't be
open to interpretation but I still think
would have been more powerful but do
kind of what they did with the saasy
beats thing we're like he just walks
away yeah yeah they leave it in your
hands yeah yeah exactly that's really
the the only thing the other comic book
moment that actually thought was
effective was when he is on top of the
the police car and then the crowd is
surrounding and it's like the symbolic
line yeah and a lot goes to how walking
in Phoenix handles that much really
really takes his time feels it was in
tune with the character arc like I would
have been cool with the movie ending
right in there after the camera pulls
away from the crowd and he's embracing
this symbol that he's become because
he's on the Murray talk show he's
talking about how he does he's not
political he doesn't care about any of
these things you know this was all
unintentional but in that moment he
accepts what he stands for now in his
existence in the world how it's become a
beautiful thing to him so I thought like
that was like the final moment of that's
when he truly became Joker visually and
I liked how I wasn't relying on dialogue
so my first thought was kind of corny
second thought that's pretty cool yeah
yeah yeah one and I like that that
becomes the the pinnacle at the sort of
end there of the movie yeah it's like
it's not like the third act he's Joker
it's like it's all leading up to that
one moment where it's solidified teeters
on the edge but for the movie that was
one where I was like I'll give it to you
yeah cuz I think the art that we all
expected was by the time he
the hair and makeup he is fully changed
and transformed but he still be still
translating evolving like even when he's
on the talk show he's still Arthur Fleck
evolving is the still unleashing slowly
you know because you do have the scene
which I think walking Phoenix acts
beautifully and one of the things I
think that is underrated for actors is
when they have to really do scenes
whether it's just them and it hasn't
really behaved as if they're alone yeah
right they're not alone a bunch of
people and there's equipment and if you
listen to enough actors talk in
interviews a lot of the times they speak
about how having a scene partner so
helpful because you could put all the
focus on them
takes your attention off yourself or the
crew in the camera whatever he has those
scenes when he's like pretending to be
on the talk show it's like yeah he's got
the vulnerable moments where he's like
dancing when he has to pretend to be the
talk show and he's trying to emulate
confidence or figure out what that
person behaves like and he's doing the
moment where he's like putting the gun
up to his chin him like yeah like I love
like the retakes he does on that that's
not it that's not it he's not
verbalizing anyway you see him like just
recently take two yeah yeah that's so
real it's like you're really watching
and dude alone in his apartment trying
to figure this out it almost reminded me
of a different version of that Rick
Dalton scene where he's alone in the
trailer freaking out because that's
another moment yeah that's felt like
that to me and it's totally different
five but yeah yeah yeah definitely like
man respect although you know I gotta
say I talked about this after the movie
was a little bit annoyed with Robert De
Niro not because of all the things he's
getting sued for right now I found out
way late last night when I was on
Twitter what's going on when the
irishman trailer was coming out him
because of what we mainly cover cuz we
couldn't tell for sure if it was gonna
be online I was watching the interview
live basically De Niro was promoting the
Irishman and Joker simultaneously
chit-chatting about Joker a little bit
and he was asked a question about
working on it they were gonna eventually
go into debut and the irishman trailer
I'm sorry way to get to the question
about what was like working with Joaquin
and then near us it's something along
the lines of I didn't like what he did
to me my mind just went well dude that
he obviously kills you he doesn't say it
but you know
just not like what does that imply
unless it's directly marrying King of
Comedy gets kidnapped and like tortured
a bit but like come on with all the taco
and runs it's too much of an illusion
yeah of alluding when the trailers do
nothing to allude he's gonna do anything
to him granted even watching them
because I've heard some people talk
about when they watch the moment where
Arthur does kill him on the talk show
that they were shocked that that
happened he might by the timing I'd say
so yeah cuz because even though I wasn't
a hundred percent sure I still think I
would would have predicted that that was
gonna happen see the problem is I saw
the trailer and I saw the talk show bit
and I was like the only way this can
work is if something bad happens at the
talk show because how is he gonna go on
a talk show I mean really beyond just
the the the shocking moment for everyone
is when he shoots Murray and I still
think it's an impactful moment there was
really no death even the death of his
mom that was necessarily like oh I'm
surprised the movie did that it was
there but it's all do you feel the
impact it always hit me though I've
always felt the emotional gravity of the
situation and that's what ultimately
counts yeah yeah I get annoyed sometimes
with people when they're like I
predicted this and I'm like who cares
because I know the original review and
and I want to draw like a line there
because I don't think it's a predictable
movie necessarily I just think that you
know it's I know I gave you mean that I
wouldn't fault it like that there are
things that I wasn't surprised happened
at all or that I could logically
conclude might but I thought they really
compensated for that with the amount of
weight and anguish they put on all these
deaths well there's a different context
to what you're talking about I'm talking
about the guy who's like Tsar coming
hate it yeah yeah that's more the or I
get annoyed actually what surprised me
was what he talks about on the interview
how that whole exchange went down you
know it was at that moment where I'm
like I have no idea what Arthur's luck
is gonna be doing I have no idea how
he's gonna be behaving or what he's
going to cover if he's gonna just try to
be funny or roll with this and then he's
gonna go oh well Joker how'd you know I
didn't know at all what was going to
happen so even the awkwardness the
timing the the pulling out the book that
I loved how he played that moment who's
still morphing he was still
uncomfortable even when he like pulls
out the book he's taking his time DeNiro
makes a jab at
I wanted to make sure I got it right
like he's still that child in a lot of
elegance such a freaking phenomenal
performance one the thing about that
soul sequence that's great is you get to
sit there wondering how much is Arthur
actually kind of jazzed to be here and
how much of this is the ruse because
that's the other thing is at that point
I think he is at least starting to
become more conniving and when he's in
that dressing room you're like I think
he's got something cooking he's not just
excited to be here and I loved that they
brought that FEMA if he ultimately says
to him you brought me on here to be your
punchline to exploit me to be your joke
and that was something that you know is
a very relevant jab I think absolutely
man I mean and that's such a good match
the theme of everything must go you see
how much he worships this guy it is
DeNiro from King of Comedy here Lewis
but this time you know it's it's
different his perception of everything
is just changing so much yo really could
want to backtrack that moment when
they're talking about why is everyone so
upset about the people on the subway
being killed because when he said that
when he revealed I was like oh [ __ ] when
he's saying that and he says if it was
me just walk all over me
I felt that like I really felt for it
that's what I meant at my non-spoiler
talk okay third times I was like I agree
man I root for you here I do you know
like I do like I gotta remind people in
real life what I have wanted that to go
down but it does Jay Leno some [ __ ] no
question of yeah it's like if you hear
about three young Wall Street brokers
being slain it's a lot different than
you know a troubled homeless person or
something like that and it questions you
know is the humanity any different just
because of their status or because what
a lot of people think about them yeah
and I think this movie did a pretty cool
job to further dissect me because this
isn't something we really even talked
about I don't think we really covered it
all on the non-spoiler talk some people
I feel like to have you know I don't
want to talk about what some people in
my mind it did bring up an interesting
perception for me personally of what if
the the way we handle people with mental
illness was had better service you know
maybe if it wasn't shunned or what if we
had laughed at or we had better
government funding for it
and whatever you know like what if we
did care more about it's a whole lot
about the I has a whole bunch of layers
yeah could this help with preventing so
much of the kind of violence that we see
in the world today from people who are
mentally unstable or mentally ill you
know I don't really know if the the
movie is making that message but that is
one of the takeaways I did sort of have
with it of a pondering moment I feel
like the movie does touch on a lot of
those it does at least bring up a
situation that you can compare to real
life I don't know how deep the movie
actually is but I think it does touch on
a lot of topics that you can then
extrapolate upon and have a rich kind of
thought process over and I think that
there is something definitely to be said
about the fact that it doesn't seem as
though at least I don't know how other
governments are but it seems here that
the well being and you know thriving
nature of the citizens is not
necessarily the priority for you know
the people running your cities your your
country overall and there are so many
people falling through the cracks and to
me this movie is yeah about neglect and
the people that fall through the cracks
because we think that there are
safeguards in place we just assume that
oh there's somebody I thought that was a
nice there's a scene somewhere where
somebody asked like well can you see
like a doctor or a social worker and
then he brings up the whole way they
just shut all that stuff down and that's
a real problem for people it's twofold
because I took away from this a big
message of like be that nice guy at the
office where it's like we should all be
a little more welcoming and accepting of
the people around us even if they are
strange or they make us slightly
uncomfortable and hey like if it's a
problem if it's a bad situation that's
one thing there is a long way that human
kindness and consideration can go and
you would argue or I would argue that
you know there's a lot of reprioritizing
our public institutions ought to do in
terms of taking care of the humans that
make up the country yeah yeah like some
stuff they I think it's really just a
dependent on your own interpretation
with it and how you can watch a movie
like this some articles or people are
like what's the big news movie has
nothing to say it's not that interesting
it does it and there's some people are
like they're so much to take away from
it a big reason why I love this
experience is because a lot of what we
take away from this movie is open to
interpretation at the same time you know
there
things that are I think are very
clear-cut and just strong quality
filmmaking there's some surprises too in
this movie I think plot wise the whole
thing with Arthur Fleck being the son of
Thomas Wayne that was a cool debate I've
heard some people say it because there's
that moment with like some photo later
in the movies as TW wanted mm-hm and
then some people take that as that the
movie is strongly implying that no he
really was the son of Thomas Wayne other
people are like now that was just the
mom Francis it's Connor oh I just wrote
that on herself right like I like how
that sort of left open to interpretation
of the matter because you could you
could see both versions you could see
that Thomas Wayne is you know not the
greatest dude in the world so easily
fabricate documents if you wanted yeah
whole thing and that's why and we talked
a little bit about this before that's
why I actually really like it's not like
the Bruce Wayne inclusion stuff is all
black and white for me up they should
have cut it out or should just really
minimized it don't show Bruce don't show
but I wish they didn't show Bruce Wayne
are you really done okay I could have
gotten on board with the gate scene if
he if the behavior that they gave the
child wasn't so unbelievable yeah he's
movie child yeah I was okay with that
because of the context of it makes sense
that Arthur Fleck would go there knowing
the character is at this point in the
story and the information he just
learned that he would just try to go in
there and talk with Thomas Wayne get
some answers resolved because clearly he
has like some real father figure issues
you know idolizing Murray from the
television yeah and he thinks he finally
knows who his father is so that made
sense to me I also thought that the
scene it works especially because of
when he does confront Thomas Wayne in
the bathroom of how he you know smooth
he's stuck in like a freaking like he's
done this a billion times a little ought
to be how smooth he did it I was saying
I'm wondering about that because part of
me was like there's no security over
here and then I was like well yeah this
movie is about what happens when you're
just invisible to every
maybe little thing but when he confronts
Thomas Wayne and if that was like the
first moment of Thomas Wayne ever
hearing truly of any of this guy's
behavior because clearly Thomas Wayne
had heard the whole incident at the gate
with the the son of what's his mom's
name in the movie oh so there's gonna be
some comment when she said my mom's
penny I'm not for a penny he already had
a huge distaste towards Arthur because
because because of that experience at
the gate so that's why I felt like it
added onto especially what because
otherwise I felt like you could have
just talked it up to Thomas Waynes just
an [ __ ] like well yeah he's got the
benefit the debtor oh look how he
mistreated penny the is a former
employee and that is so like doesn't
give a [ __ ] about Arthur at all but
adding on the context of his behavior at
the gate and having that information
reporter to him and how after he hits
and misses don't go near my son again
yeah that I felt added more layers to
the resistance of that conversation in
the bathroom it's very yeah I think the
scene definitely serves a purpose I just
it was one of those moments in a movie
that I wasn't having a lot of this
response it was one moment that really
pulled me out went okay this has
happening because it's a movie and we
need a cool movie moment where he puts
his hands in the kids mouth I'm like
what kids ever gonna let you do that so
yeah is it have you met kids you know
yeah facebook comments on our page yeah
this is like so long ago and I never saw
this comment and some guy who was like
look I don't know who Derek Mitchell is
but joking about kidnapping kids isn't
funny I remember this joke I think it
was some kind of weird thing about him
being like a kidnapper in an uber cuz
yeah you did like uber or lyft at the
time we've made some like a little side
comment
I think that seam does serve a purpose
and I think it does add to the grayness
that I appreciated around the whole
mystery with Arthur and his mom in
general because you do have something of
a back and forth going okay is she
making this story up or is he's just
trying to cover it up because it is an
embarrassing situation that a rich
person that we've seen in our own
society people cover things like this up
I ultimately fell onto the side of
thinking that his mom had been
delusional and sort of through the
treatment this is this is funny because
I was I was having a conversation last
night about nature and nurture in regard
to this movie and this movie makes such
an allusion and an argument arguably for
nurture just because it's like the abuse
and the delusion passed down and just
all that and especially - they bring up
that detail about head trauma being a
main cause for his laughing disorder and
I feel like that was the kind of
clincher for me on that side of the
story which is they found him tied to a
radiator with severe head trauma I feel
like that's probably the case yeah but
even so I just thought that whole thing
was tragic so it was very tragic
after watching King of Comedy and taxi
driver this week it's like the king of
comedy things of like Oh old ER
gentleman who lives with his mom
worships talk-show host and I like how
it didn't mirror the outcomes of any of
those relationships in that movie
especially with the mom the journey he
went down with going to the hospital to
try to uncover his history now because
not only does he have these like hey he
doesn't know his actual lineage then
learning about his upbringing that he
just seems to have completely forgotten
about I like how that dealt with a lot
of physiological and psychological
disorders that this guy had you know
just also Bray I think it that break is
really significant because you could
argue that his mother is like the one
kind of benevolent consistent presence
in his life and if she is responsible
for this big illusion yeah that's
horrible why he is the way he is and he
just like hates himself and part of you
know redefining himself he has to let
her go let her go just murder her right
which was a heartbreaking scene and I
gotta say - in the trailers when they
that lot line I used to think my life in
tragedy but now I realized
a comedy than having when he says
[ __ ] comedy in in the actual scenes
like the cut out word it's a comedy and
I thought that worked really well one
thing too is I appreciated the execution
of how they handled the mom you know
they didn't really treat it like this is
creepy or weird or unsettling I thought
they would like double down on like
creep factor with the relationship with
these guys you know she seemed like a
pretty sane woman hit throughout this
whole movie the way Francis did her
performance she's like I've seen her so
much play like crazy weird people on
American Horror Story that I thought
okay they're gonna get that for her even
with the bathtub scene you know there's
something that seems a little strange to
me about it the way they framed it I
couldn't tell if her actual nipples
works like in the context of the scene
where nipples exposed were they
underwater either way I mean he's seen
his mom naked a lot yeah and it's given
a lot of baths and I certain area there
that I feel like some people might just
find to be a little strange and weird
yeah because it's your mom she's naked
in your bathing oh yeah yeah and there's
the caretakers side like no it's not
weird so there's someone really a big
subject here but I thought from watching
the trailers that we were gonna get
something that was a little bit more on
the nose of how like this is really a
kind of twisted relationship yeah and I
thought it was good to play it the way
they did especially when he does kill
her that way it's not like yeah [ __ ]
had it coming yeah it is sad and twisted
ya know yeah yeah it's a delusion and
it's a sad delusion and it's unfortunate
the way that all these events had to
unfold yeah cuz even when she hasn't
moved where she's hiding from him in the
bathroom and like I'll go you know I'll
come out when you're not angry we don't
even really see him like losing his cool
her and I thought that was smart I feel
like there's a lot of deleted scenes in
here primarily because there's actors
like comparin the entire cast is only in
like one scene II the exacerbates we'll
talk about just saying like yeah well
actually you know a beads which I
thought was interesting and how they
handled her character here because when
she showed up after he was stalking her
and then she's like were you following
me earlier and that she seems like she
was like charmed by it
yeah my mind was going to work my mom
wasn't going to what the movie revealed
as the twists as I eventually just
accepted it yeah it was like uh-huh
because I'm I went and what woman would
be okay maybe mom maybe weird attracts
weird I guess and then I also went yeah
the single mom thing and then my mom
would I wasn't around during the 80s
maybe eighties New York women were okay
but I don't know a really really really
forward guy and then now when you start
to watch the relationship unfold and how
he's doing his stand-up comedy no one's
laughing but then it cuts to her and it
wasn't even like uh-huh okay are that it
was like she was really like supportive
and proud of him in that moment one the
way that moment even plays itself with
the sound fading out like it's beautiful
when you look back on what the outcome
is because it does make it feel like
it's going great
yeah they're on the date and then the
thing with the when she sees the the
paper when he's looking at the paper
clown vigilante and she's like yeah he's
a hero
yeah yeah they're playing all these
things and I like who who's this isn't a
real person he's here in the hospital
with his mom now I chalked it up to
lackluster writing on the character oh
yeah they're for a good chunk of the
movie being like this is the one element
that is like horribly written why is she
why isn't she a character at all and
then the reveal comes around and I was
and the way they handle the reveal I
thought was really well done when he
first says like you're are you're Arthur
you live down the hall and you have that
moment to be like wait a minute what
yeah yeah because I did say what my
girlfriend Olivia went hmm like she
wanna bleed
yeah and I was like wait why what'd you
say like oh yeah and the way they did
that whole revealing oh my god and then
they ain't just walks in the hallway I
thought was great I'm just leaving that
open to you maybe he killed doesn't come
back around at all in this story but
yeah so like even something that I
wasn't on board with they got me on
board was you're like yeah it's not rosy
for this schizophrenic type of
delusional behavior yeah
this is how he fantasizes and would
interpret this situation to be
you know take that one little elevator
exchange and run with it yeah yeah that
was that was uh that was wonderful
that was great don't forget we can't
forget that that scene with the door
lock oh yeah this movie has a lot of
commentary on mental health mental
illness but they're not shy of their
little people jokes I don't know how to
if you're a little person comment
because like I wonder how it is for that
actor cuz I gotta imagine it's hard cuz
a lot of little people probably get
hired to be some kind of a joke our
punchline and this movie does have some
form of sympathy for that character but
is also pretty mean to that character I
sing father lets all my people were
laughing really hard actually there's a
lot of scenes where it was a really
mixed crowd where people were clearly
we're getting what this movie was trying
to say and then other people were
laughing really hard at moments that I
just I personally thought were like it's
kind of disrespectful you reminded me of
the people in the subway that are
seriously they were like oh you're the
that's who's being reflected when you
hear them I talking that theater and
stuff and it's laughing at moments that
I'm like no this is a disturbed moment
for this character
you're like people were here people who
were free you know but with the little
person I thought that added such tension
in that moment did which I thought was
great well done because you know he's
gonna kill the dude who dick them over
you know that scenes gonna happen and
then when he kills him it's so brutal
and it's not one and I brought this up
near the end of our non spoiler talk
that there's not one death in this movie
that warrants up yeah yeah there not one
death even in the moments right like I I
kind of side with him a route for him or
I sympathize for him I I never had even
in that death moment cuz I'm like whoa
that's pretty straight yeah and and what
made it so even more real was the way
that character the little man was acting
responding his his like freaking out a
terrific background like it's not like
he's screaming he's yelling yeah you
can't believe what's going on and I love
the way that moment played where he's
like I'm not gonna kill you
you can go and starts walking pass and
he like yeah he freaks out yeah it's
like such an uncomfortable moment
because it's it's funny yeah kind of
don't want to laugh at it and then you
have that moment of fear of like is
Arthur gonna change his mind did Arthur
intentionally put the lock on there yes
playing with his food right now yeah
yeah and then it's like did such a great
job attention in that scene because if
he does let it go he's open the door
then he closes it again and you're like
he's gonna change his mind he's gonna
kill him ah this is the moment where he
ate Arthur yeah he says that line you're
the only one who's ever nice to me then
kisses him on the head or something lets
him go I thought was just beautifully
played like it was a beautifully played
moment and I like I like how them the
movie never and we talked about this
earlier terms of how the transformation
goes down at that point he's still
morphing so he doesn't just immediately
morph into I'm Joker I'm gonna kill you
anyone anything choice yeah he's Arthur
on the way up yeah yeah all the deaths
in this movie I thought were handled
with to uh with a certain weight even
like the cops in this movie it's like
the East fence that's what I mean about
how I don't think this movie encourages
violence against people with money or
the police or something like that
because even when the way the cops are
killed the way the movie plays is a lie
on the subway station when they're
chasing Arthur down it's a really good
tense chase scene it looks like the cop
out of the gun goes off by accident
because even his response is like yeah
and then they all start jumping him and
Arthur's laughing at them and dancing
while the one cuffs being stomped to
death that's a very unsettling moment
it's not played in a way like ah screw
the cops hey you know and the
ramifications do come back because there
are a couple of moments I think where
somebody confronts them they're like two
officers are in the hospital now because
of you like yes on the talk show yeah
and so yeah exactly so you know I like
that those consequences are kept and
it's interesting because I get the
complaint about the fact that the movie
basically kind of shows you something
and leaves it up to you to interpret but
that feels very akin to the Joker in a
way it feels akin to the whole thing is
you're supposed to kind of take it in
and see where you land and what you
sympathize with and which of these
tensions you see reflected in the world
and the thing I really did appreciate
the thing that surprised me the most in
terms of
actual like shock on screen was the gun
like every use of that gun he gets is
scary and punctuated and and you feel it
yeah and I thought that was a thing in a
time where gun violence is such a big
issue and for a movie that is a part of
that debate at the very least I thought
that they did a nice job of making that
gun a horrific presence no matter when
it showed up yeah yeah I mean specially
and that's like even before the subway
scene when he's with the children kids
yeah and then the country officer like
cuz you're expecting something bad to
happen but that's not it yeah yeah it
just drops out you're like oh this is
awful this is like a whole other caliber
of bad like on the subway station when
he's being really quick as far as we
haven't really dived of into this the
choice of what they did with the laugh I
think was great because when someone's
cast as the Joker you you automatically
ask two things what's their voice as the
Joker and what's their Joker laughs
gonna be early on in this movie you see
this laugh where he this is a shot just
on him laughing looks like he's like
choking on it like he's gonna caught me
yeah it's it's it's a it's a physically
uncomfortable laugh for him to be doing
he can't stop laughing it's almost like
it the more tense of situation gets in
the more he wants to stop the less he
can yeah and it's not like they
instantly explain that moment when he's
with the social worker like he goes on
the bus tries to make that kid laugh and
I thought that was a really fascinating
way to infuse the laughter of the Joker
in here no this is like a traumatic
thing this is intense isolating this
yeah yeah that's a great way to put it
this isn't like oh he's morph into evil
villainy and this is where this laugh
comes from I thought that was a really
beautiful way and and and the way it's
handled in so many scenes that caused so
much disruption in his life from subway
people to when he's just getting
uncomfortable ain't hit him is he see
like you think this is funny and you
can't explain it to him he can't get the
card in time yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like he has to rely so much on this car
yeah to try to get to people and even
with the kid on the bus
yeah with the mom you know he doesn't
intend to and it's heartbreaking every
time because no one understands no
stranger understands why this really I I
haven't
looked up I heard this is based on a
real thing yeah yeah it's a real
condition and I mean you know I'm sure
that there are discussions to be had
about that but I thought that to make
though it really made the laughs a
presence and a character of its own to
do that and it gave it a meaning that
really contributed to the overall
character portrait that's going on here
it's like the laughs is an iconic aspect
of the Joker but here it is something
that is intrinsic to Arthur it's painful
but also over the course of the movie as
he gains more control you watch him
engage with that laughs in different
ways like when he laughs on the talk
show I could swear he had some control
over that like you watched his eyes and
his mannerisms and the way he's looking
at Murray and that laughs feels like a
put-on well it seems like as he learned
to embrace himself more The Laugh was
suddenly not a an issue yeah or at least
it goes yeah there's that whole
explanation about inappropriate moments
or whatever and it's like the more he
becomes himself and the less he tries to
manage it it almost feels like he's just
free and the laughs is free yeah
absolutely yeah but back to that subway
station when he when he is laughing and
1980 how they include they work for
Thomas Wayne and then the one guy
apparently his musical interests one guy
knows that whole song really memorized
all the words big big fans might be a
douchebag he's probably gone up but he
knows his old-school classical when he
shoots them I thought it was smart to
actually have the first kill he does be
against people who you're like it like
oh there's a gray area yeah these guys
might use a gun in this situation and
ourselves yeah there's a defensive kill
and they really made that clear but then
they but though but the way they extend
it he gives he first shoots the first
two and then the third guy he's hunting
down you know like yeah waiting for him
outside of the cuz this is a mess the
doors and then he like attracts them to
the stairs and shoots him and then goes
alone to the bathroom is dancing it's
like bringing out this side in him he's
not reacting at all how he thought he
might react like he's feeling more free
I thought using those visual dance
moments was great to express like this
level of freedom that he feels I just
move that way Joker is in the dance
with the devil in the pale moonlight oh
it's it's as easter egg we're like
hopping all over the place anything we
missed that we must cover just the final
final final ending oh yeah mm-hmm
the credits they love the way the
credits were done actually the title
text silent movie layout it's cool it's
weird I guess so everybody's are a lot
of people are taking that final in a you
know a interview room scene in the
hospital as sort of a capper to say that
this movie is basically a story that's
being told in an interview therapist I
don't think it is and I don't think
that's intentional for people to feel
that way I didn't feel that way either
yeah I didn't feel that way funny enough
both taxi driver and King of Comedy
both have endings that people have said
those are delusions hmm that those are
fantasies from the main character's mind
in this movie clearly borrows from those
films Scorsese has come out and been
like no that's this is like they
eventually apprehended him because they
probably would because both movies have
the same thing where you watch it care
tax Jenner can both have a character
psychotic who morphs and then they do a
time jump later on show where they're at
then and then the movie ends those two
movies and this one the way they're shot
I can see why people feel like oh it's
gone into now that was the fantasy like
not the ending itself as a fantasy like
it's different here the ending here has
got people thinking was the movie we
just watched made up like it was a
fantasy and his mind as opposed to is
that ending moment of fantasy because
that's how a taxi driver and King of
Comedy were taken but here no I don't
think that I thought I was just a jump
forward yeah I thought it was just like
a surreal coda to put it in almost a
cartoon with the guy chasing him back
and forth yeah then it's it that was the
moment where that was the appropriate
comic book II moment to me was like
we're gonna have to walk out with the
bloody foot stash he's probably he's at
Arkham I'm I'm going to assume Arkham
because of like whole scene where he
goes to arc I'm talking about what it
takes to get into Arkham yada yada yada
it would make sense that he's an article
yeah with the bloody feet and everything
and I'm like yeah that's that is like
Joker he's like nothing they haven't
Arkham and killing people yeah and hunt
him down and he's gone gleeful and
maniacal
about it yeah than that a therapist's
replacement will be Harleen Quinzel down
the line then we're gonna swap out Jer
Leto
with Joaquin Phoenix that's gonna mesh
oh and though recut Suicide Squad with
all new footage from Joaquin Phoenix
I mean I'd watch it I don't know if it
would make the movie quote good but I
would watch that that moment in the
sewer and the birds of prey trailer
I wonder how people are so confused when
they watch that was like the words of
Prayer trailer played right before Joker
and for those who don't keep up with
strongly being able to know this is
nothing to do with that timeline I
wonder how confused they must well how's
this gonna tie into that trailer we saw
margot robbie you're gonna be the sequel
yeah she can break him out what about
the other Jokers your little just
replace your really different characters
I should have played that trailer before
this movie I'm like it makes sense
because you're promoting your next DC
fellows just throwing ideas up but
anyway yeah I didn't view it as that I
was a little bit confused as I like the
moment where he says nobody's laughing
about so what's so funny you wouldn't
get it like out of a joke and that cuts
to like that image of Bruce Wayne
standing with his see I still think it
probably would have been more effective
if you eluded I feel like you still
could have had that shot but only when
Arthur's remembering or like fly don't
know why Arthur's remembering because he
wasn't there to the crime but I mean it
was a famous death so I'm sure he liked
it well yes I was gonna say maybe he
heard the report and he's like haha what
what how ironic
I've orphaned this child yeah his father
is one of the many aspects of my
orphanhood yeah yeah yeah sorry I got it
I I eventually did get it like by today
but in the moment I was actually a
little confused I still think it would
have been more effective if you didn't
show the death like you do like we do
the alluding that we thought of and then
you just show that image when Arthur's
remembering or thinking about it then I
thought like oh that would have been
cool to show that you don't see the
in-between you just see the walking to
the alley and in the final moment that
could be yeah release the Gregg cut good
great I'm buying a bus dad I'm buying
billboards we're doing it it's the same
exact movie I just trimmed down one
Zuri makes it a couple bits with Bruce
Wayne just one minute less and run time
this is the definitive fully way this
was supposed to be studio now it's a
room I meet a lot of like unrated and
extended cuts of other movies they're
just like we put in 30 seconds more gore
and I'm like great does that mean you
added point five seconds on the end of
every gore gag that's pretty much
everything right I think so no let us
know in the comments yeah well you know
I mean we haven't talked about Dick
Grayson being in the movie or the
crossover potential with Nolan's
universe or Tim Burton making a cameo
all right guys well whoever has stayed
around this long kudos to you kudos
I don't know how interesting so we're
not [ __ ] Joe Rogan two hours
oh yes stayed here this whole time I
appreciate it if you did comment if you
stayed only comment if you made it this
far only comment just to say yeah I made
it yeah you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell well catch you guys on the
flippety-flip